hey everyone JK and I'm with John Luke
we just finished watching the Mass
Effect Andromeda gameplay trailer at the
video game awards and we broke it down
there's a lot here so let's get into it
yeah first off just shown a lot of cool
environments really really excited about
this a lot of variety yeah it looks
great it looks gorgeous really good I'm
really lots of lots of diversity um huge
range in planets that looks like
absolutely should to find a new home for
humanity alright so right here let's
pause yeah this is this is big yeah we
got a galaxy map here first thing to
notice they have an activate scanner
scan planets yeah looks like that's
returning one thing that has me worried
though and I pointed this out before is
I don't think you're going to be able to
fly the tempest from planet to planet
this is rumored before but seeing this I
don't think so i think you're still
going to be plotting a position on a or
a planet in a galaxy map and then you'll
go there however i don't think they'll
be loading in between those planets
because they have said it supposed to be
a seamless experience but i don't think
you'll be flying the tempest i hope i'm
wrong but you never know yeah i like to
look at this galaxy map a lot the the
sort of the nebula yeah it does the cool
and there's a progression of top so it
looks like you will be kind of chipping
away at that as you explore these
different planet very much right in and
one into a lot not so much three
but in Andromeda resources are scarce
worlds are hazardous or outright
uninhabitable every planet has its own
story Oh going back there just want to
comment on how cool that looks that's a
black hole is that what that looks like
yeah because we cleaning around a black
hole or something which ballocks nets
looks like they were flying into it too
oh man I really want to see the inside
of the tempest I don't show that in this
that I really was okay go couples frames
here we go to new squad members we got a
Krogan and we got a female turian which
they showed in Mass Effect breeze DLCs
the Omega DLC in the Citadel one but
they've never really been a part of a
Mass Effect game proper so I'm really
excited to actually like have a full-on
just turning squad members yeah that's
really awesome I also like how the
krogan has like tusks on his armor
that's pretty cool yeah that's that's
pretty rad and here's the first sort of
a civilization looking thing we've seen
it yeah got a hub area right here she's
talking to a person named Sam who's got
a robot voice imagine an ed like yeah
I'd say so probably probably housed on
The Tempest exactly or maybe the Nexus
notice right here at the top on your
little compass a lot of different icons
it was shops it looks like a lot of side
quests stuff like that you were talking
about sort of just the aesthetics of
this area yes so I mean this looks very
temporary or that it was built very
recently I know a lot of people were
pointing out like how come there are no
aliens like new aliens on this area and
I think that's because this the
Andromeda initiative landed here and
built this up pretty quickly yeah I'm
gonna see this calm conversation lots to
look at here yep the krogan right there
rocking the n8 classic assault rifle
from aspect and there it is okay
dialogue wheel first off a little mouse
cursor so something that we were
thinking was this was being I was
thinking of us being played on the
PlayStation 4 pro because it's running
in 4k and it's showing PlayStation
buttons clearly but that little mouse
cursor they're kind of gives it away
my theory is maybe this is just a PC dev
build that is probably this probably
what they're shooting for on the pro is
my guess yeah I'd say that's about right
and then here we have four options it
looks like there are more options right
off the bat maybe I know by the time we
got around three usually it was just
like good thing bad thing yeah and right
here I mean up top you've got like I'll
be honest with you that's probably your
paragon whether or not Paragon renegade
will stay in this but that seems like
you're good choice get over yourself
seems like you're sort of renegade
choice but then there's also none of
your business and let's cut the cut to
the chase which also seemed pretty rude
to me yeah in the middle here we have
the face with this little swirl not
really sure this world means but that is
clearly taken from Dragon Age 2 and
Inquisition where they would put little
icons to kind of give the player an idea
of what the tone of what they're saying
is going to be because that was always a
huge complaint with this dialog wheel is
you're never sure exactly how rude or
how polite you're going to be about it
so a little touches like that really
help just point me to where you're
holding him and there won't be any
trouble they won't be and this is
awesome yeah so this is the return of
the interrupt system from two and three
they've made some pretty smart changes
to it for starters there is now text
that actually tells you what you're
about to do the interrupt system never
told you that so you'd run into a lot of
issues where you would press it and then
you like shoot a guy or punch him in the
face and you look well it it's not what
I wanted to so really what I was going
for but sure that works so kind of
giving you a sense of actually what
you're about to do is smart also the
circle is kind of like has this bar
that's filling up that will tell you how
long you have to actually press it which
is also good yeah another thing I
pointed out to is that there is no
renegade or Paragon logo there while it
is red so I'm assuming that's sort of
like a negative thing to do and disarm
point a gun at them probably negative
but still it doesn't seem like they're
focusing as much on like this is a good
thing to do and this is a bad thing to
do
ok now you first get out or I'll put you
down all right here's the nomads in
action the top left we have a mining
scanner which is pretty cool uh it's got
a boost I wonder if I has a jump I don't
know um I mean X maybe is a jump like
they are going up yeah yes squares boost
though it looks like and then L too we
don't know if that is I think that's
repair yeah I like from from aspect one
yeah here we get a scanner a couple
things about this for starters in the
bottom there are these three little
circles and the one on the left is the
Andromeda initiative logo we're not sure
if the other two are what we're thinking
is these are different factions in the
game and somehow you're getting points
towards them not really sure how that
relates to scanning yeah I mean that
seems like the best bet just because
they're all next to each other like it
yeah I'm not entirely sure what that
means but they were saying early on in
the trailer that like this planet there
are factions fighting and you can kind
of pick a side so maybe but yeah I like
this whole thing here it's kind of a
very Batman like yeah solving a murder
mission variety I like that kind of
stuff and I we go about to see a lot of
combat okay so first off this UI very
mass effect 3 the they are clearly a
biotic by the purple health probably a
vanguard because if the classes are the
exact same because they have a shotgun
and then they also use the biotic charge
we see the two squad members down there
which confirms that there's probably a
three-person squad total yeah I think so
and then throughout the trailer you see
that squad number chain that the squad
images change and it seems like there's
about five people we can figure out for
your squad we got this female on the
left here not really sure who that is on
the right you were thinking maybe
another turian I I think that might
actually be p be no there no PBS later
you guys clearly pv um but then there's
also hockey's it looks like again and
you can assign presumably you can assign
biotic powers or powers to l to r 2 or
pull both the triggers one
thing that I'm kind of curious though is
that if L tues use a biotic power I
wonder how you aim good question a one
maybe that seems weird we don't do that
anymore though they don't show it I
wonder if you can still pause pause and
kind of aim do you like the aim pausing
yeah I got less emphasis as the games
went on so I'm wondering if they will
just maybe take that out also your
weapon has a fire ammo associated with
it and you see like different ammo types
well this is sick yeah they do the
biotic charge so specifically if we go
back here I will almost certainly play
as a biotic just so I can use my jetpack
and biotic charge together a lot of
silly uh and you see there they warped
back and then they actually hit this guy
with like a blade yeah she pulls out a
knife yeah that's pretty cool and see
their shoot with this like almost gray
day like shotgun right hit there she did
this warp like dash which seems to be
the replacement for the role from three
and actually in the maastricht
multiplayer different characters would
have a different version of the role and
the asari had like a biotic work bored
with this sort of dash so it seems like
there may be just you have that now
except that it's more through the
jetpack then maybe a biotic ability yeah
it seems like the jetpack will play
pretty big role in this yeah and who's
this this is new yield that's pretty
cool now there's a tech armor that's
returning a lot of mobility yeah I like
that that you don't see them ever
getting a cover I at once you seem gonna
get some cover up top yeah but very
limited here we got the weapon wheel uh
the top seems to be focused entirely on
weapons dr. animos back and the bottom
seems to be focused on ammo one thing if
I go back a second right there there's a
button that says holster weapon which I
is really cool because I'm mass effect 2
and 3 didn't let you do that yeah one
did I just I like games that let you
like put your gun away whenever you want
I just it adds to the sense of yeah
drink for me I wonder if you can get in
those mechs the way you could in mass
effect 3 that'd be really cool
hey there's there's cover mm-hmm and
then just in general these environments
remind me a lot of mass effect one's
environments yeah very open obviously
quite a bit more detail yes way much
nicer I actually want to be there so you
have these pods that seem to come down
and our theory is that so Mass Effect
one you could switch weapons and armor
whenever you wanted but in two and three
you could only do it from the ship and
my theory here is you can do it outside
of the ship but you have to have a drop
pod come down for ya in mass effect 3 2
1 one way you could change weapons was
these work benches scattered throughout
certain missions and i think you're
right i think this is sort of a portable
way of switching weapons like if you're
about to take on robot like like like
one of those hydras is what if you're
about to take on hydras then you might
call this thing in and get like a rocket
launch or something like that and then
you mentioned there's a lot to show here
so we have to break it down you
mentioned that the guy says you can find
salvage or steal yeah which is something
interesting because you've always been
able to do sort of renegade or evil
things in the Mass Effect games but it
you've never actually been able to like
walk up to something or someone and just
steal stuff I mean you could take stuff
out of crates but they never call it
stealing I wanted that I hope we're not
looking to into that I want that to
actually be like a tan I do too i think
that Bailey cool a lot of stuff
happening right here there is your
characters level up on the top left next
to it is an item limit which seems to be
returning an actual inventory which one
had and they kind of abandoned after
that under that there is a weight limit
which affects your power recharge which
was a thing in mass effect 3 i'm curious
if that is dependent on your characters
weight or actually like item limit like
if your inventory actually affects that
highly just don't think i don't think it
would be your inventory i think gets
your armor and weapons yeah there is a
credit and then there is a nexus level
yeah so i'm not entirely sure what this
is i'm gonna guess is that as you play
you level up the nexus and that allows
you to explore different solar systems
different planets could be wrong but
that would be that would be my guess yep
here's your different armor types there
is a button for mod so hopefully mods
are making a return from aspect one can
mod your armor
your weapons stuff like that looks like
you can kind of customize the color of
the chess pieces is what this at least
seems to be maybe I don't know there are
actual tangible effects on these armors
a tech damage seems to be at least
hopefully like a little bit more
tangible than mass effect two and three
they had tiny boost but honestly yeah so
inconsequential that I just picked the
armor that looked the coolest same with
me one thing you pointed out to was
placeholder chest armor description is
all their work in progress everybody
yeah this is gorgeous yeah this looks
great and then here we are collecting
minerals getting that hot lithium you
were saying how you were your a little
worried about this yeah I don't want
pop-up menus all the time but but it
says their codec entry added which
implies it's the first time you picked a
blue themed side open that's just a case
where it only happens the one time and
then it goes away this thing looks
brutal yeah I like the idea of just
fighting random creatures again yeah
we'll get go thing that and then that's
that's a grenade there yeah it looks it
reminds me a lot from Mass Effect 1 how
you through those discs grenades this
one has a little bit more of an arc and
it's also assigned to a quick slot if
you look down and looks like r2 yeah but
like Mass Effect one it seems to have an
actual number associated with it yeah
is that a lot of the dash dash that's
really cool and they're gonna get
munched move tasty all right a lot of
powers here this seems to be a new
different character right here they have
a tech power they got this text shield
yeah and as you can see the shield is in
a biotic one so probably tech that guy
doesn't really cool flame for a half ago
flamethrower and then if you look up top
you see vetro loyalty mission so they've
already confirmed that loyalty missions
are in fact back but this is just
another example for proves yet more
proof and then like I wonder who venture
is or thinking maybe it's the female
turian yeah she's down there on the
bottom this right here is a cool little
just like uh looks like a sort of like
arc ability some sort of tech ability
Yeah right there it's a skill up you get
skill points I'm curious how the tech
tree is going to work in this one or
directory the the skill tree and then
another thing to point out to is up in
the top it says eliminate hostile
remnant forces the sort of architecture
here looks a lot like what we saw in the
PlayStation pro yes keynote so I think
that this is I think the remnant are
going to be the sort of main antagonist
the main antagonist I don't think we're
going to see Reapers and I think remnant
are what we're going to be focusing on
this time around yep and then also shows
that you leveled up you can reach up to
level 24 which Mass Effect one went up
to 50 and then in to you went up to 30
and then three could go up to 60 if you
imported your save so at least going up
to level 24 i'm gonna guess 60 you're
gonna get sex video 60 platic charged
invisibility is back also at the corner
here we see there's a heat hazard level
I like that the return of sort of
environmental hazards yeah those do with
something we saw in one but they kind of
got rid of it in the other ones there
were certain scenarios where you'd have
to like watch out for the Sun or would
it watch out for the sun's intense raise
but this actually looks like a planet
you land on could be actually
inhabitable which would make sense not
only in concept but also at the
beginning of the trailer yep the the
narrator says a lot of stuff happening
here
knife fight i'll see if i can get this
one yeah awesome this is a like really
rad looking I don't know it's like a
giant rod a hammer thing that our
writers is about to beat someone down
with that looks really cool and they're
doing around town you have this ground
pound which could be done in mass effect
3 2 and the gas way and then getting
grabbed again they really like to show
you getting wrecked yeah all right now
is the trailer that's the Mass Effect
Andromeda TRO that was shown last night
at the video game awards if there's
anything we missed and I'm sure there
was be sure to let us know in the
comments below or you can find us on
Twitter and for more on Mass Effect
Andromeda you're already in the right
place a new galaxy await how far
go